ثم تتساؤلات عن المكاسب الاقتصاديه التي
ستحققها الجزائر من انضمامها الى مجموعه
بريكس لاقوى الاقتصادات الصاعده الرئيس
الجزائري عبد المجيد تبون اكد ان بلاده
مهتمه باكتساب العضويه التي وصفها بانها
قوه سياسيه واقتصاديه وان الجزائر تستوفي
معظم الشروط المطلوبه اما وزير الخارجيه
الجزائري رمضان لعمامره فاكد ان لبلاده
القدره على تقديم قيمه اقتصاديه مضافه الى
بريكس بينما رحبت الصين وروسيا بالخطوه
الجزائريه يعود تاسيس هذا التكتل الى عام
2006 بمبادره من روسيا ومن المفارقات انه
وزراء خارجيه الدول الاعضاء عقدوا اول
اجتماعا بنيويورك وفي القمه التي
استضافتها البرازيل عام 2014 وقع قاده
بريكس على وثيقه لانشاء بنك للتنميه براس
مالئه مليار دولار وتوفير احتياطيات
النقديه مليار دولار اخرى وذلك لمواجهه
تاثير مؤسسات الاقراض الغربيه ولعدم
الامتحان بشكل اكبر للدولار
وعاده ما يوصف هذا التكتل بانه يستهدف خلق
كيان موازن لمجموعه العشرين او مجموعه
السبعه لاسيما ان دوله الاعضاء تمثل 40%
من مساحه العالم
تخبراء يرون ان ابرز المكاسب الاقتصاديه
التي ستحققها الجزائر تتمثل في ان بريكس
تضم دول لديها معدلات نمو اقتصاديا مرتفعه
مثل الصين والهند والبرازيل ومن ثم فان
طلبها على الطاقه من الجزائر سيرتفع كما
ستمنع الدول الاعضاء الجزائر مزيدا من
التسهيلات التجاريه والاقتصاديه والماليه
وترى الجزائر ان النظام السياسيه
والاقتصاديه العالمي اخذ في التحول بسرعه
من نظام احادي تقوده الولايات المتحده الى
اخر متعدد القوى تقوده الصين وروسيا ومن
هنا فان انضمامها سيوسع قاعدتها
الاقتصاديه ونفودها السياسيه
من سكان العالم وتمثل ربع الاقتصاد
العالمي وسته عشر في المئه من التجاره
العالميه كما ان الصين اكبر مستورد للطاقه
في العالم ما يعني انها قادره على استيعاب
كميات كبيره من صادره الجزائر من النفط
والغاز
واخيرا يتوقع الخبراء ان الرجيم يمكنها
تخصيص جزء كبير من استثماراتها الخارجيه
للجزائر في بلد تشكل مصادر الطاقه اكثر من
90 في المئه من صادراته